(audience applauds)
- All right, so we've talked
to Molly about her shows
that are just crushing it.
I can think of something
else that might bring
that same fervor, and it's a
little movie called, Scream.
(audience cheers)
So there is a new Scream coming out
and what I can gather,
and talking to Courtney,
and a few of the alumni and
a few of the new cast members
is that they're taking an interesting
and different approach.
Can you tell me anything?
Without getting arrested in movie jail.
- I can tell you that I love
playing the role of Dewey.
It's such an iconic role, thank you.
(audience cheers)
That Matt and Tyler were inspired by Wes
to become filmmakers.
They're the two directors
that are part of a group
called Radio Silence that did the film.
But they were inspired by Wes,
so they really wanted to make a tribute,
like a real something
that he'd be proud of.
And there's an incredible cast.
I mean, I think people are
really going to be excited by it.
- I think-
- I can't say anything 'cause
I'm talking in circles.
- I don't know you guys are-
- It's like I'm falling fishing.
- You guys are Angelinas,
do you all know about
the Hollywood Forever cemetery screenings?
- [Audience] Yes.
- Okay, these things are legendary.
I mean, I'm talking five, 7,000
people show up on the night
to go to a cemetery and watch movies.
And they did a slumber
party just a few weeks ago.
I know because also
Billie Eilish texted me
and showed me that she
dressed up as Casey Becker.
And I've recently made friends with her.
I'm freaking out.
- [David] Oh my God.
- And it's like, you
have literally legends,
like Billie Eilish showing up for this.
This movie has stood the test of time.
It's capturing the hearts
of our generation, new generations.
And a film like that
deserves not just a sequel,
but a re-invention and a
respect for the classic.
(audience cheers)
I'm really excited about that.
And it'll be great for you and I
to see that legacy alive and well.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪